hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it's
the 21st of May today and the show
you're watching right now is games what
news first up today that new zelda game
hyrule warriors got itself a release
date in japan the hack and slash action
game will be coming to the region on
august seventeenth of this year and if
you don't remember it's a collaboration
between nintendo and dynasty warriors
series developer tecmo koei reportedly
the game will be a wii u exclusive and
we're yet to hear if it'll be released
outside of Japan let me know whether
you'd like it to be or not next up
alienware may be making a pretty
sweet-looking steam machine but that
doesn't mean they have any faith in its
success Franca's or general manager of
the alienware game pc division said it's
going to be very challenging this will
absolutely be the least profitable
system we ever sell alienware haven't
announced a price for their box yet
although they previously expressed the
importance of staying competitive with
current consoles which is probably why
they're a little worried the first
actual gameplay trailer for Batman
Arkham Knight has landed and like most
trailers about the Batman it looks
awesome the trailer features epic scenic
shots the iconic bat-signal batman
looking broody standing on to all things
and of course the Batmobile the video
closes on the enigmatic Arkham Knight
saying there is no Savior no more hope
no more Batman the game is expected to
hit shelves this fall and is set 12
months after the events of Arkham City
if you choose to pick this one up you'll
be facing off against villains like
scarecrow penguin to face and Harley
Quinn again the xbox one's newest system
update is coming and here's what you can
expect out of it if you want to identify
yourself with your real world name
you'll now be able to do that and
Microsoft is adding external storage
support you'll be able to connect up to
two external hard drives which must be
at least 256 gigabytes and use USB 3 the
xbox will format your drive for you and
you'll then be able to copy and move
games and apps as you please as for
other features being introduced the one
guide and universal remote control
functionality now works with SmartGlass
one guide is also set to come to canada
the
UK France Germany Spain and Italy in
june when the update launches let me
know in that commenting section down
below what you think of the xbox one's
upcoming update that is it for me today
but be sure to join me again the same
time tomorrow from one new things I will
see you soon